natalie is in canada hi natalie welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
um i'm trying to figure out a few things
but the main thing is
whether or not to uh try
and get my husband on board with selling
our house i've brought it up a few times
but
he really doesn't want to sell it at a
loss
we moved a year ago about
an hour and a half away from his current
work he planned on getting job
job around where we live we live in the
middle of nowhere
with the intention of being able to grow
our own food and just
be out in the country again where we
both kind of grew up
and anyway it hasn't happened yet he's
trying but
uh it hasn't happened we uh just
realized you're expecting another
so we've got one toddler and another on
the way
um so he has a job it's just an hour
away
an hour and a half yes so he's traveling
about three hours a day
but the income is uh he takes home about
uh
31 000 and some uh 30
almost uh 31 200 a month
and um we don't have any
um uh real issues exposed with spending
that we're aware of we don't you know we
don't have any money subscriptions
we don't have any money no we don't have
any money
thirty one thousand in the three hour
drive a day i know where your money
and babies i mean you're only any money
no
i i don't know how to convince them
we're both believers um
unfortunately because of covet all the
churches are shut down the one we did
get to know it's it's closed now and we
really haven't
developed any sense of community around
here how much do you owe on the home
natalie
okay uh so so far we have
we um oh it's around
280 000. okay uh
it was 300 just under 350 thousand when
we lost are you making a payment on that
making 31 grand
well we're losing we're leaving every
month how
um we i mean you're losing humans
well uh no
not yet we have oh you're eating up your
yes for eating savings for savings yeah
i would guess how much is your house
payment
one thousand one hundred and eighty
three dollars
and how much do you all have in savings
right now
oh we're burning through it uh we've
probably got
yeah right now we've got a thousand
nine hundred left to our names in liquid
and you're burning how much no um
we are burning i drove this down too got
all kinds of papers in front of me
um 2707.40
so you don't even have a month left
not really no not really i mean two
thousand over nineteen hundred you don't
have any money left
yeah i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do um
i'm trying to okay i don't look let me
okay i'm a little bit confused let me
let me stop
i i don't wanna okay uh i i don't want
to
uh take your side and jump
all over him right now but that's how
i'm going that's how i'm feeling i don't
want people well because this is
absolutely asinine
that you guys have let this that you've
let this burn down to this y'all should
have been out there six months ago
i agree and so i don't i don't
understand why we're in denial about
math
what's his problem he doesn't want to
sell it at a loss
i don't care he's going to lose it to
foreclosure i know but you said you
bought it at 350
correct and it's now you owe 280. so
what's it what do you think it's worth
now
i wish i knew we we haven't gotten the
price okay
so here's the steps i think in sitting
down and really sitting down with him
right hold his hands and i want you i've
scheduled a i've scheduled a a
real estate agent to come over here
tomorrow night because tonight we're
about to have a come to jesus meeting
the math is over we cannot that we
cannot pretend anymore
you've got your head stuck up something
i don't know what it is and it's got to
come out
yeah this is ridiculous and put put his
hand on your belly and let him know
you've got another baby coming
this is crazy time time i have he's even
finished your book
we we bought your book on amazon he read
it he's
so excited so gung-ho he's not going to
look for more jobs now but it's
it's just it's not it's not about jobs
it's about this house is gone
yeah yeah yeah it's gotta be it's a
three-hour drive with a pregnant wife
who's scared
and he's out of money this house is gone
sell it before you lose it yeah what do
we do do we rent or
um you move to town and rent when we
went there
it was 1800 a month you're gonna have to
get other jobs but listen what
your your little dream of living in the
country and growing veggies has turned
into a nightmare yeah
yeah i know and so something's got to
change we can
you cannot stay where you are yeah it's
not going to work now then the only
question is where are we going
right and you got to start figuring that
out as a next step but this i
i i don't know what you were waiting on
were you waiting on the housing ferry to
show up
i mean it's not this isn't you know
unless you were going to have an income
all of a sudden start appearing that's
double yours it's not going to work
this is not going to work it's not just
and so natalie the urgency you hear in
our voice
is that we don't want you all hanging
out for another two to three months you
don't have
that you're never gonna come get the
house yeah you don't have that time
so i would much rather you all make a
proactive decision reach out to your
lender have a real conversation
get the real estate agent the real
estate elp over tomorrow
you are moving yeah voluntarily
or otherwise you are moving much rather
you be in control
this is where you are and so let's face
it and decide what we're going to do
where are we moving because we're moving
you know
yeah this house is gone i'm so sorry i'm
sorry you guys have been through this
but you've i you got to deal with it you
cannot
you cannot not deal with it anymore